yes good morning we've got nate
tannenbaum taking a look at that
possibility uh because should we cross
our fingers that it's a good rain
this has been junior weather buddy
discussion
yeah we're trying to get into the club
you know you talk i talk about an
exclamation point i think it's mostly
going to be a shrug
we're talking about maybe a passing
sprinkle got a live view for you here
lots of cloud cover but when we show you
the radar pictures i think you'll see
what i'm talking about but we'll start
with the official temperature at
mccarran it's 55 under that cloudy sky
just a little breeze we're five degrees
warmer than we were 24 hours ago because
of that cloud cover but we're really not
anticipating much if any accumulation
there may be a better chance for rain in
fact it is raining right now south of
the 15 back there down around towards
barstow and baker also into northwestern
arizona so dolan springs you may be
picking up some rain but our futurecast
showing at six this morning again most
of the stuff will be to the south and to
the east of us it'll look like rain and
it might try to turn into something but
let's take you hour by hour real quickly
here maybe a sprinkle in 54 by 8 storm
clouds lingering but start to get out of
here already the sun will come back out
this afternoon with an afternoon high of
62.